[Music]
wake up early in the morning press play
and let's get it in cause we rocking
with the fighter
[Music]
how can malcolm x don't have a day white
people don't like him he have a movie so
that's yes
i mean that's what they say yeah you
love that movie don't you
oh yeah that's denzel get your hands on
my pockets
honestly i think that's number one
brother brother star that brother star
for knowledge
you think that's his number there's
number one movie of all time i love the
beginning too yeah
there's that name of better training nah
nah
the way he had hurricane was dope
hurricane was
wait wait why are you white hurricane's
good it's good denzel
yeah yeah we're talking about something
it was three hours in a three-hour movie
i know we got a movie and he's
soaked number one
here's the red here red part like
slavery
and then he's in prison because they
robbed that that uh house and harry's in
prison he's putting that
treatment in it and the brother because
you're putting that poison in here
the white man with the poison
he said all right begin to read i began
to write all those books every black
letter that was on that white page i
began to study
train my mind yo
i'm just surprised not malcolm x dad i
know he's kind of violent but
yeah did you read up on it or something
oh yeah that's
the the his murder too is interesting
interesting yeah
i read a book about him uh while i was
in maine the first time brother she was
interesting as [ __ ]
hey you know it's funny you remember
when uh lebron james was just carrying
around the malcolm x book for no reason
and the reporters like asked him
hey what do you think of that what do
you think of the first page no he's like
man
so why was he doing it that's lebron's
problem though
but he carried it for like weeks yes but
he he [ __ ] up and his
where his marker was and never moved
never moved through and it's like what
page you understand what [ __ ] you mean
what page you think i'm up
yeah we're halfway through the season
bro
well game 72 what that hasn't moved man
so dee you've just been in baltimore and
maine this whole time
maine baltimore phoenix nashville
now back in baltimore floating around
i'm floating man
also there's nothing those are also the
only places that are open
like nashville in phoenix yeah you can
get up and like that's true and [ __ ]
around you know
baltimore was open they closed that [ __ ]
down but and how's it going with your
girl and her family
it was going good but how long have you
been though have you ever said you're
welcome
i think so yeah this is the problem yeah
we didn't we
weren't here to go they they invited you
they invited us they were like but they
didn't invite you for
several months they were like come stay
cove it baby
yeah come come stay and we were like oh
we don't have to we kind of like the
woods you know we're doing our own thing
and they're like oh no no come
come stay so you go stay in their house
and man i i think they were like as
slowly as time went by they were like
oh he's a [ __ ]
sam said i left i fly out yesterday to
come here
the moment i had a party the moment i
left i had a party and they were like
hey so
he smokes weed huh oh yeah is he smoking
the weed are you smoking a lot of wheat
at the house
never in the house but yeah i smoke weed
outside the house yeah
but are you high 24 7 around the family
no 20 12 6 3.5
you know it's tough to get comfortable
at your your girlfriend's house
i mean luckily you ain't blowing up the
bathroom we got our own spot like the
basement so the basement
in the basement it's it's own apartment
i'm tired of putting in my
basement you know what i mean okay i
agree but yeah okay
okay it is a nice place though it is
more
yeah so you're staying there with your
girl in the basement
everything's good you guys eating
dinners together we didn't we always go
eat dinner with a friend because they
invite they're like hey come up and eat
dinner and they can
make it what they make they can cook or
is it wipe it's like real white people
follow me hold on
speak your truth man do it
white people taco night is real dawg
it's fantastic just like that taco
tuesday taco tuesday but it's just you
know when it's real lebron tried
claiming taco tuesday
white [ __ ] bro everything is everything
is a pot roast
yeah [ __ ] yeah you like that oh yeah
yeah keep going what else
oh god she's all excited everything's
just burgers you know what i mean
yeah did she introduce you to the
scallops yet bro hey scallops go hard
potato scallops come on bro
out there yeah i got in the crab since
i've been out there oh crap
crazy oh you [ __ ] with crap crab cakes
crab suits oh yeah that's big out there
yeah
yeah that shit's fire okay so let me get
this straight go ahead because
he's nice nice nice nice place to live
they're making crab meals mac and cheese
pot roast
where's the problem here okay problem
the real problem is i'm just there
yeah they don't want you around they
don't want again have you overstayed
your welcome you know what i'm saying
like you're probably like all right dude
dude i feel it but this is my thing i
was like we would have never came
sam wanted to go because she wants to
spend time with her family i'm like you
know absolutely
covid we're not doing we're just sitting
here in l.a let's go sometimes we spend
some time with my family hurt okay let's
do that let's spin i haven't seen my
family in forever
let's go see your face that's a long
time it's a long time bro
they're not [ __ ] having it man so how
do you know did they give you a timeline
or anything they never said anytime they
just said come they just said come
on so what do you expect them to do what
do you want but what are they doing
like how do you know that you they don't
want you there anymore they told sam
that they don't want us there anymore
derek is it both parents or one parent
it's one that's the thing
and it's the stepmother that's his dad
loves me the dad
loves me loves that and they're
that parent that stepmom she's always at
home
stay home mom exactly oh there it is i
like where you're going but the kids are
grown
kids are growing everybody's out the
house everyone it's it's except you it's
me so you're her
syndrome brother she's got down syndrome
who lives there
oh but she takes care of the kid with
down she takes care of the kids you
watch him as well
24 7 bro you know episodes of the flash
i've had to [ __ ] watch
he loves the flash dude i know the
[ __ ] so you're
kicking it with the down syndrome
brother 24 7 me and him kicking it
[ __ ] cracking jokes watching back to
the future way too many times but i
don't mind
this is this is how it is
bro and then you could feel it i could
feel it though when i was leaving of
like
of like oh man you're gonna go out to
lay be great if you could just stay out
there huh you know
just like yeah it would and you think
it's cause you're black
definitely because i'm black part of it
why are you saying she's making comments
there's all the comments like during the
riots she's like wish they would have
got in
bro during the white people rioted on
the recent one and her
i didn't also i never talked politics i
just walked upstairs and she was like
you see this
i mean this is bad but imagine feels the
other side right derrick and i was like
i mean yeah
[ __ ] can't act right was that what you
want for me we don't know how to act
is that what you want like what the [ __ ]
do you want lady
also it's like bro i don't i hated to
just are they into politics
in the politics i hate comments you see
them
hate god i'm just there dude and like me
going like oh no
no i'm like i mean comedian like this is
like i've been doing before i met
her and y'all this is what i was doing
and i was in this [ __ ] yeah
was in and are they mad because you're
not like chris rock
matt that bro to them it's like you know
the kind of people you talk to and
they're like
oh well i mean you know there's derrick
and then there's like chris rock well
you're not you can't be chris rock and
it's like
you're like well how did you know there
was a point where chris rock wasn't
chris rock yeah like
they don't see that they don't
understand the journey i don't
understand that there's a journey
you know patrick mahomes didn't go from
high school to [ __ ] the best player
in the nfl
there's some stops on there there's some
stuff there's some troubles you know
what yeah there's some bumps yeah
but they're not you know you just talk
to people and they're not they don't see
that man they don't
like my parents get out of there man i
don't that's why we have yeah
that energy
what does that mean it's an ugly girl
that lives in a cave
it's a bad like if a girl's ugly like oh
that's a cave babe ugly girl or guy
okay
i love myself or a guy
you're watching uh love island season
three and a new girl came out ooh that's
a cave baby
she's like what's a cave baby went it's
an ugly [ __ ] that lives in a cave
and she was like okay yeah she was like
oh okay i guess that's a thing
yes that's just what is
you'll hear about this there's a lot
more around this house that's that cave
baby
babies no that's that's that's your [ __ ]
and leave yeah is your girl heart broken
about is she close with a stepmom
heartbroken just because of the
non-belief yo when i told her
i told her i was on she was like so what
were you doing before all this
i was like oh i was on tour and then
literally cove it happened like yeah
stop like it just stopped
just stopped everything that was it and
she goes were you on tour or was your
nfl friend just taking care of you oh
and i'm like how did do you even know
darren how the [ __ ] did we get here
you won and like you should look you up
or something you never told her i don't
know i did your podcast so she probably
actually i think she saw the malik
episode thank you
or like saying things of like uh you
know like oh were you a comedian or were
your parents
just helping you and like stuff like
that where you're like oh this is i
can't
she has a little bit of racism in her
you can feel it feels like she's
watching cnn like [ __ ]
derek god damn problem
and we're helping them out this is part
of the problem
we gotta do a huge thing one night about
healthcare and i was like why am i
talking about this
because she was just like something like
how no one deserves healthcare like
unless you earn it and i'm like
i mean yeah but who care like who cares
right and poor people get healthcare i
don't like it doesn't affect
like what you know they should they
should earn it like we had to earn it
you're just like oh what who is with
this weed
it never comes up that i'm black never
talk about it they don't acknowledge it
don't ign yo if something happens
like where it's like some black [ __ ]
yeah it's not
it's obviously racist yes uh not
not like it didn't happen like george
we're not talking about that what what
do we want to hear your opinion on it
no don't hear my bro if we if they or
they'll be like you know
uh like ask me some a stand-up question
right like like oh so like derek you
have you ever met like uh jim gaffigan
gonna be like oh actually yeah like i
thought you were on the front oh okay
damn he goes nowhere are you gonna get a
job
ask me that too i'm like i didn't have
to come here but what's sam say a
heartbroken she's more heartbroken on
just the is she close with the stepmom
closer to the stepmom and then
the non-belief like the like hey i'm i
like this is what we've been doing like
way before [ __ ] yeah cover just put a
halt there put a whole you know so we're
figuring it out like we're not like
you want me to stop now also nine years
you want me to stop this
yeah nine what do they want you to do
just ju and also it's just like what do
you want me just like get a job just
like oh well you gotta you gotta go out
here
that's what i'm saying i'm like you want
me to work at discount bob's tire shop
in baltimore
yeah but i didn't even have to come here
but sam's a comic too i know
the non-believable works at the comments
in their head sam's not a comment that
doesn't no
bro she was just a girl who had a job
and she's dating me that's what they
were like
what is this are you really doing this
or is derrick for you yo they told her
tell us if they're forcing you to do
this no yeah legit questions
yeah i kind of like this stuff
she doesn't realize that sam getting
hired at the comedy store is a big deal
big did not
have an idea no idea it was just oh you
gotta oh you got a job at that comedy
place that sells
okay did they watch the documentary at
least at all it's not
true it's not really if they're not into
it it's just it's just not a thing it's
just like oh well you're not you're not
also telling them
for me to make it it wouldn't even be
like if i hit like
i'd have to be furious no not even that
i'd have to be like oh he's hosting
family feud
yeah look at him he did it they're just
old they're just older they don't
they don't get it and also just not
trying to and that's why i'm like well
i'm not gonna sit here and try to like
tell you what i'm doing old and racist
that's a tough
combo oh yeah you ain't changing their
mind and then then you know then you
know
you got some anger because she's dealing
with the kid with down syndrome all the
time bro
and that she's never worked and so like
i think that i think that too it's just
because the dad goes and works all day
does construction comes home
sees me and sam you tell he's just like
hey yeah what up y'all
[ __ ] yeah y'all you in her space where's
her i'm in her space yeah
i'm in her [ __ ] you're just there and
i'm just there yeah my black ass
face and i'm sure everyone can weave
bro you know you know like sorry what's
her name
sorry amy ate all your pot roasts you
got real
high and in all your pot roasts you're
like these people are ridiculous man
cause i'm [ __ ] okay those king crab
legs that you [ __ ] bought last week
me and my girl ate all of it i'm like
yeah man i mean i'll help out with the
kid with downs every now and then but
i eat all the crab legs i get high i'm
smoking actually getting on me like
[ __ ]
this is so weird it's just a metal meth
pipe you know
yeah you might have to get out of there
i got two dudes on the right day too
mark with the kingdom
left perfect timing is there is there
anything to do in maine now is that open
a little bit
mains not open no
i don't know there's no one there yeah
there's no one there it was me and 32
old white people
hell yeah in the whole state chilling
are you vibing bro what up marianne you
know what i mean
uh but yeah bro that [ __ ] was crazy dawg
that's that energy that energy's so
[ __ ] when you get before you get back
to you
you can when somebody's like get the
[ __ ] out of my house
with their yo and that hurts more that's
just somebody like yeah here another day
huh yeah
ooh still here huh still yeah just okay
pot roast up there again yeah yeah don't
try it yeah try it
they know i'll be honest with you they'd
be offering seconds you know before i
finish my first plate
you're gonna go get another one huh do
you pretty good pretty good huh you're
gonna take something to go huh
downstairs
tough situation but it's one of those
it's like man i can't have you have you
been getting up at all
in phoenix yeah that's the only place to
get up but me and chapelle talk about it
earlier he's like he's like bro i've
been to the same
five states yeah i was gonna say yeah
we've been you know
what else you're gonna do i have seven
offers from just all florida
for real i'm not even trying to be funny
literally my agent goes hey
uh uh marcos island and i'm like where
am i going
island where's that fiji's like it's
flora
let's take a little break from the
shenanigans with derrick poston because
this episode is brought to you by blue
chew let's talk about something called
used a little more right now
malik and his girl definitely want to
partake in this we're talking about sex
that's right gag balls lube whatever you
want to do you can now increase your
performance to get extra confidence in
bed listen up bluechew.com
that's blue like the color blue blue
chew brings you the first chewable
the same fda approved active ingredients
as viagra cialis
take any time day night gag ball lube
don't matter you'll be ready to go blue
chew is made in the usa
it's prescribed online by licensed
physicians so you don't have to go to a
doctor or wait in line
it's cheaper than pharmacy and they
prepare and ship right to you discreet
little package
no more awkwardness nobody needs to know
just get your dick game right
right now i got a deal for you guys
visit bluechew.com
get your first shipment free when use
the code fighter just pay 5
shipping again that's b-l-u-e if you
don't have spell blue prize shouldn't be
having sex
b-l-u-e-2.com promo code fighter to try
it for free
blue chew is the better cheaper choice i
thank them for being part of the podcast
remember when you support our sponsors
you help this podcast so please
make sure you use the promo code fighter
bluetooth.com here
at fighting the kids we're introducing
you to proactive to consumers who have
acting looking at clear skin visit the
website
proactive subscriber i used it when i
was a kid
thank god man we all have stress in life
from little to big stresses with all the
stress in life
acne should be one of them can do
something about it now from stubborn
breakouts
to occasional pimples proactive has you
covered man do you know that pimples do
not happen overnight
acnes always seem to appear you got that
pimple before a big event
whatever you're trying to do listen
proactive got you covered man listen
proactive comes in three
systems man practice solution the
original the original
system suitable for all skin types all
right they have the proactive md
advanced prescription strength for
stubborn breakouts
you have the proactive gentle maybe got
scented skin we got you covered man
all right they have three different
systems all designed for you
to get your skin looking right and right
now
is a great time to try proactiv for you
guys you can get a special limited time
offer
by going to proactive.com fighter
subscribe today you will get
a practice hydrating duo as a free gift
that includes four hydrogel masks and a
green tea moisturizer
fellas can't wait to jump on that best
of all you get free shipping again visit
proactive.com
fighter take advantage of the special
offer now that's dot com slash fighter
subscribe to
get clear skin yeah i was gonna say yeah
we've been
what else you're gonna do i have seven
offers from just all florida
for real i'm not even trying to be funny
literally my agent goes hey
uh marcos island i'm like where i'm like
oh an island where's that fiji he's like
it's florida right outside of
tallahassee yeah yeah
you know and i was like wasn't that
close to tampa he's like it's all good
i guess i want to keep flying to florida
dude i mean you're flying
six hours yeah every month that flight
that's right it's better nothing it's
better than that i mean is that texas
arizona arizona nashville nashville
tennessee it's like five years
yeah jim boise was like and he was the
first comedian to ever yeah
and now that uh now felipe's there yeah
joe coy's going there yeah
fluffy yeah one there too i was like the
coveted canary in the coal mine in boise
and that [ __ ]
was lit lit at first i was trapped
up and it was one of those like oh no
like a haunted house kind of thing yeah
yeah literally like a haunted house yeah
it was terrible but then is
dope so but they're like don't post
video don't be all up on instagram like
let's just
let us do our thing they were not that
[ __ ] let me tell you how lit it was
each of us had our green room we all
stayed outside right there by the stage
just chill those are the best [ __ ]
places bro when there's like five green
rooms
it's so like for mute from musicians
yeah the place where next week
in san marcos texas it's uh music venue
they've never had comedy either oh
really what
are you the first from the first man we
just break yeah you broke
down here i mean we were the first there
breakdown we didn't know till the night
up no they like
you're going on stage like hey by the
way you're the first person to go we've
never done this before so
the sound check what
i was like you've never had coffee you
need a microphone opening night
oh [ __ ] open it like do you just shout
what's your thing what's your lights do
you want lights
do you have puppets the [ __ ] is
happening
[ __ ] awesome they're open now they're
good they're open uh i think i saw
preacher was just there
oh yeah yeah yeah florida's wide open
there's only a few but it's gonna start
listen 2021 it's gonna
gradually start to open because new york
cuomo is like we gotta open this yeah
ridiculous yeah chicago's like this is
ridiculous we gotta open so
once those big democratic states are
like hey we're opening
california has no choice but to [ __ ]
yeah they'll have to bro oh i mean also
what the [ __ ]
they do it's the biggest state
everyone's leaving they're losing all
these businesses like what's your plan
bro
what's the plan how about new yorkers
like uh legalize marijuana
mushrooms everybody gets three mushrooms
yeah please stay they're panicking
yeah schultz is out because here's
what's in about uh new york
they're like hey we're opening up so
restaurants you can open you're like
[ __ ]
it's negative 20 outside we're not
trying we can't
so they're open but it's negative
[ __ ] 15 in new york so no one's
eating outside
so can they go inside now no no only
outdoor
dining and it's snowing it's [ __ ]
it's you're in new york in the world
it's
from new york oh it's miserable in the
winter it's a beast
and there's no like the outdoor dining
it's not like new york or l.a where it's
like open
like the streets are [ __ ] so there's
nowhere to go it's freezing
so schultz is taking off to miami so for
like three months he's like until more
[ __ ] opens gets hotter i'm taking off
he's his whole operations can be run out
of miami damn damn that's [ __ ]
tight right it's [ __ ] actually he
said miami's like do this
miami's besides atlanta is the most open
atlanta is open yeah
atlanta didn't get the news it's covey
no they don't know
nashville nashville is popping up
bananas popping
yeah you don't have to wear a mask and
they know you don't like
yell at you nothing they go yelling
they don't make you try to make you feel
bad for getting your mask in the car
yeah bro make you feel like you killed
somebody damn
crazy well it's awesome that you're
going to phoenix though phoenix is lit
bro
how's the comedy [ __ ] i want to do
tempe but my
uh agent was like well it's kind of it's
only like 20 minutes away from
it it is only 20 minutes away but
tiffany's lit it's important yeah
yeah because that's where the i mean
yeah like i don't know downtown never
done tempi downtown's like
it's it's like newer like up and coming
where tempe's you know
pretty much been yeah it's old school
and like they got asu right there so
like
it's just yeah it's just lit they got a
ring they go they go crazy you got a
raisin candy's outside oh raisin cans
raisin cake come on man there's always
raisin canes
raising candies is great right diet
though y'all are still
i'm not with them on the diet but you
know on a diet we're on a diet
i uh
[Laughter]
i i i yesterday yesterday i was good
yes i was super clean okay because
really my diet started yesterday because
yeah you get something you saw what i
have for breakfast now
you took a walk yeah i go i go to get
some fresh air for breakfast
starving yourself is not a diet
basketball
i mean that's what you were like hey
derek just so you know i'm going to take
a nice little walk because i'll get the
[ __ ] away from you it's seven in the
morning oh hey dude yeah you wake up
for a little stroll
do you want you comfortable at my house
yeah yeah
eating all my [ __ ] he had wings last
night but y'all didn't even save me
money
because you weren't active enough i
wasn't y'all working
[Music]
me white mike we got a bunch of greens
that's his name because he's so black
yeah like i was like you know if you're
like in the hood you'd be white
we got a white mic in aurora he's great
had like rims and [ __ ] all the time he's
white mike
that'd be a great movie did you know
white mike before you uh yeah
i met him i love white mike he's awesome
mike's great yeah
yeah he stopped betting you white mike
stopped that he started he [ __ ] he
fell back he's a sweeter man you need to
follow the [ __ ] back
you got to chill you need to chill out
you need to stop what's going on
let's just go a few events so it started
with ryan garcia versus your boy the
english luke campbell luke
campbell ryan garcia was a minus 6 40.
you took luke campbell
whatever easy picks thought you'd learn
your lesson you bought me
shoes yeah shoes shoes
that was after the knockdown he still
took the bet yeah so yeah you bought him
still waiting for the shoes
then you bet what was the next bet we
made we better
was it so again it was a football game
it was a game uh i can't remember bill's
ravens
wasn't up against my bills
i was on the bills for three days
don't make people open was on the bills
for three days me and steve tasker okay
chill out me and don bieby
support the bill's mafia bills beat the
[ __ ] out of the ravens they beat the
[ __ ] out of them
it wasn't really a game it wasn't it's
kind of a boring thing so does that
matter
as soon as that interception hit and it
was pick six that's when you start
throwing that's where you started
texting the group you was nervous though
the whole time
yeah so i got i got a net uh old school
kyrie irving jersey coming
wanted durant you got me kyrie i guess
i'll wear his jersey
he won't be there for longer okay not
here
and then i won another bet and then i i
have the uh hardened jersey coming
i said you bought that you bought the
jury sent me link it's not coming to the
end of
march that's what that's he's in high
he won the hardened jersey for that
coming to the end of march yes again
i i ordered it i sent the links he sent
me i'm like here just
anyway so so far i've got two nuts but
but that's all set on that shirt you
said you just then i
shoes yeah okay i like shoes and jerseys
yeah
this was the worst bat out of all you
were talking [ __ ] in florida about the
saints
this is everything i said came to
fruition i said drew brees is garbage i
said it on this podcast okay and a lot
of fans came to me that was like you
don't know sports shut the [ __ ] up well
look how you feeling now he sucks
i said peyton manning i said he sucked
and he didn't
always say something no no
saying in playoffs does he up his game
or does he uh lower he's pretty [ __ ]
good he upsets a lot of times it's not
up he's like no he does not brother rams
he he had the rams that went super bowl
they got [ __ ] literally
a lot of times the saints just had bad
luck like one play
i'm glad you brought up the rams uh game
because guess who [ __ ] fumbled on the
50-yard line
[ __ ] through brazil oh yeah that's
right he did it
so you talk all this about drew brees i
don't know how i don't know how somehow
you got super hype about new orleans and
went i bet you win the super bowl
and i said there's not a chance in hell
they win this
ball you said really let's bet i said
okay malik
i'll take every other team but the
saints you a deal i said shoes it's a
deal i told you
you bet him if you win i'll buy you
seven
that's what really got me though because
that's a really bad
bet on you me wait wait that's right
that's how i made it yeah
made it fair [ __ ] me up saints win and
they were at the time their third
favorite to win the super yeah
if saints win i'll buy you seven pairs
of shoes mess me up if anybody else wins
you owe me one pair of shoes
that's it saints got lost last night i
sent you a link to the shoes that i want
and then i was sex texting jay offline
like i feel bad alex awful at better
awful i don't know why you keep going
four grand another one hold on hold on
no hey
so he listen he's like you know what i
feel like he said listen i feel bad
no shoes i was like man don't feel bad
we got another bet pending on sunday
i said i'll take the chiefs but patrick
my homeboy has to play no you said even
you said
no no no you said
i go you know patrick holmes if they do
it right he's not going to play on
sunday
there's no way you can get knocked out
like and then get cleared to play
he couldn't stand up yeah he could do
that he was insane if they allow him to
play they're going to do that
they know what's that so even if they
allow him to play
there's no way he finishes the game he's
going to finish the game he'll get
knocked out of the game
you know how concussion like he's going
to be so susceptible to get knocked out
all we need him for the first half
on the first all you need is a lead with
the uh the chiefs they don't give up
leads now come on man
nah if you got me haney henny haney
where the [ __ ] his name is
he's been home he has 15 years he iced
the game listen
it was a hut he threw the pass then ran
the clock the game he did not he did not
win the game
that's a big no no
mcdermott send my boy a jersey
come on [ __ ] that's job 43 what's up
nah it's not bad but you said i'll even
i'll even take
even if batman holmes doesn't play i'll
bet you they win i said all right deal
what do you want to do
shoes you went yep and i went malik why
don't you give it a few days watching no
you didn't no no no no no hell no nice
cheating
he goes i said espn no you say you have
until wednesday you try to ice me a
little bit your ass on this one
yeah he goes he goes i was like i don't
know if my homies is playing and jay
intervened he was like malik
calm down i wouldn't take that bet let's
see what my home does right we gotta
know
he goes he goes nah you have until
wednesday i said
until sunday he was like yeah
but he hit the deadline that jay was
like hold on but we've you talking about
vegas rules
vegas lines you don't place the bet
until the game starts like that's when
the deadline is so i have until sunday
to make the better now that's fair
that's fair hey
why are you bullying him thank you you
see what he does you know he's bad at
betting
no i know that's why i stopped is he
bullied no he is or is he trying to help
you no no he's not trying to have him
my money but look here's the thing this
is what he does though and i hate this
like right now i'm just chasing the
money
i'm looking for any and everything that
like get even because he doesn't listen
he says he's undefeated but he's really
not i know i've never lost i
yeah you guys yeah i've never lost you
you gotta l england
not to our group i haven't but you know
what it is you take bets that are safe i
take risk
what i mean yeah it makes sense but it's
bad it's
really bad that's a bad thing don't do
that man
it's an upset waiting to happen well
i'll give you this sunday to make that
yeah exactly
all we need is what are we in the back
shoes you already have all the jerseys i
mean what are you i'm all set
god it's really just about hurting you
at this point i don't need shoes
it's mainly about your pride and here's
the shoe it's not cheap shoes that he
gets he wants
she won't ask for kids no
he's not asking for filos
felix
amy's
that's not what it means what does it
mean i don't know that's the only the
term i know but i know it's [ __ ] you
by us [ __ ] you about us
my dad tried buying a fubu shirt when i
was a kid i bet your dad's like you
can't wear that
he's like why i'm like it's forrest bias
he's like by who
oh as a kid i was like black people
please don't buy that and he was like
size it up he's like oh you know the red
one with the
white fb i'm like yeah i'm like please
don't bubble letters
that's what it [ __ ] means oh that's a
lot
that's a lot federation internationally
associated
i didn't know that was french what's
good french either
what's loot so
have you all met his dad yet i have not
no no you haven't
well because coven yeah yeah you won't
leave the house
he's going to get vaccinated why but he
met derrick because i was hoping i was
so curious if he treated y'all to say
what he saw
when he got me real my dad so my dad
grew up around just black people his
best friends are black
like he grew up so he was the white
might yeah he's bro he sees brittany's
like hey son
hey hey jay how's it going buddy he sees
me my [ __ ]
what did i do baby you got no calories
so weird yeah
he's like those colleges
threw up in the green room i remember
that very vividly your dad sounds
awesome though
yeah yeah yeah it was so she was like
how about
hey
his best friend's name was like harold
growing up this black guy and they used
to sell wood that's not
that sounds about right yeah they said
oh yeah harold and him you sell what's
your dad's name
peter peter yeah
in here
yeah bro apparently yeah i didn't either
you've been to the comedy world never
comedy works it's great i don't have it
okay
it's it's smaller than this half of this
size and you know jay's also half of
this room
so yeah that's a lot of throw up it's a
lot of
fun [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] made him throw up just
this one shot like a pterodactyl was
throwing up okay
that was like jameson but like that like
strong james that chin jameson
yeah that's that
i love the peer pressure i gotta take it
a month off i'm like i mean i mean well
next week obviously i'm gonna [ __ ]
throw a couple back i'm not gonna oh
when he gets to austin he said he's
gonna it's on
yeah i'll drink with because i'm doing
rogan i'll drink with rogaine dude we're
gonna we gotta
get some food food yeah great best thai
foods in austin
is that what you said wait hold on hold
on absolutely yeah that's what you're
saying there's a great time
yeah in austin texas barbecue thai
it's good mexican out there let's get
food over now talk to me about this uh
so you say it's a thai food it's nice
you know i love some food this place is
dope
me my girl eat thai all the time come on
really the one on uh
this one
no we go to the spot called toronto run
something like that you never heard of
toronto
well you already heard of it
is it is it that vegan [ __ ] right
you know vegan thai food that's what you
and your girl be eating
what have i ever eaten vegan thai food i
thought that's what you guys eat you get
like the pad thai
pasta you no i do that pineapple fried
rice okay chicken
oh give it up dog oh yeah you want me to
do it with the tim
the korean spot you took me to last
night was [ __ ]
[Laughter]
no but this this [ __ ] is fire brother
crispy it looks like the hot is gone
that was insane that was so [ __ ] good
at that at that time
they do this uh [ __ ] thing where it's
like wood
in the soup yeah no it's like bamboo
bamboo bamboo yeah
huge announcement cats are the only fans
oh yeah
[Applause]
my big toe is the biggest toe you've
ever seen i've seen it yeah
you gonna wash your feet
hey dog you gonna watch him yeah watch
your feet we're in there we're in the
air
that's what i always ask you about hey
dog you can watch
that's so [ __ ] stupid though yeah my
big toe is outrageous yeah outrageous
yeah i'll send you a bit
what made you like go with this like
career choice well
well it's just a side hustle it's good
side hustle
it's going to make extra money and i
just wanted to get my feet out there i
feel like there's too much pressure on
me hiding my feet yeah
i just need to get them out yeah but are
you only opposed
feet or it's only gonna be feet you
think only feet
attention is my drug extra money is
though
yeah it's not intentional it's not
attention it's like it's good money
and they ask if they asking for it they
ask the demand is there yeah and also
fee people are so [ __ ] cool that's
the thing fee people are very nice dogs
they look
cool or weird no nice neighbors say
they're serial killers
out of all of the dms i get people are
always the nicest you don't focus
uh i mean i i want my girl to have feet
but
there's really like no good feet i feel
like there's a regular foot in bad feet
that's
like if i'm watching a porno and the
girls like using their feet to jack them
off like that
i'll fast forward what comes back really
yeah what kind of feet what
was that yeah what yeah that [ __ ]
happens it does
yes they just be out there just like so
they take their feet take their feet
yeah check them out i'm telling you yeah
i'll watch outside
why are you acting like you've never
heard of it until they take their no no
i swear
to god what are you a parent
so they do so they physically take
everything
this motion no yeah man with a lot of
lube
a lot of loop it's very straight yeah
i'm on that loose [ __ ]
so really i just got introduced to lube
so you like butt stuff
no not butt stuff what's the loot for
them it's facebook come on
good time for me and my girl i'm with
eric on this it's only no
no no a show could put you on no way
i didn't know it's only for the for the
butt bro no it's not bro
you gotta you go you go with that dark
out no you don't go in that dark alley
listen you put it
no i'm talking chappelle oh you go down
that log cutter
i just say mainly justin right justin
was like listen if you do this you're
going to love it because
again was like man we just did we did
everything right so he was like bro i
don't know we need to spice it up
spice it up with butt stuff dude no no
no i don't go nah
chill i don't we i'm not in that ass i
mean i'm not in that butt stuff
you don't know though what do you mean i
don't know i looked up right now
oh you [ __ ] up no no
you're going you said you're looking for
a good time
and you said you got luke you know you
[ __ ] up no
because the one because when i hear lube
there's only one reason you're going to
do it i'm trying to tell you bro
it's you go straight in now here's the
thing i listen to justin justin said bro
go crazy
i didn't know what that meant so i put a
lot on oh yeah you can't
feel it i'm wet she wet like that's how
it is now you're [ __ ] in the pool
yeah there's just nothing going on i
didn't know that but now we i took i
took it off
all we did was but if you have to use it
every time dude no we spice it up
candles what are you talking about we
have candles set that doesn't gamble
what is going on that has nothing this
is a rv music video
i'm romantic
lube is where he's at bro dude wait so
you're putting it on your penis
just for the vagina just so we can
mathematically get it right yeah
bro she's so wet whoa bro
you know that's luke she can do that
without the loop yeah but no
again it's like it takes it to the next
level yeah you said you said that try it
try it what we do we have a whole set up
like we planned on ourselves i heard you
heard the candle
no no i heard the candles in the 500
you know word puzzle yeah
we do the crossword puzzle app every
morning to stimulate our mind
and we just try to tell each other like
this morning i got three minutes
broke my record oh [ __ ] she figured out
in 52 seconds but you know who the smart
went in
hey but it's all good though back to
what you were saying so you said
yeah you said yeah i do want to i don't
know i don't do the
don't do the dark alley have you ever
done it no bro i stick my i stick my
finger in like a bowling ball you know
like
and now i just go in oh you did that you
didn't have to do all that
you asked me questions but i didn't need
to see oh my listen i understand the cat
it is a little strange needs lube just
for the basic [ __ ] right
it is a little off because i don't think
because your girl is younger right she's
30. yeah she's pretty young
that's pretty young yeah well she's no
guess she's older than me no no kids no
okay
no kids
it's a lot of work man yeah sometimes
i'm late because i'm going to drop them
off
why what and she has to have lube yeah
you never stuck it in the dark alley no
wait time oh everyone
in here went to the dark alley so i just
i never have
okay why are you why are you
i was yeah asking you a question i said
you don't go to the doctor i don't go to
the dog i got it i was just curious bro
okay all right all right do you have you
so you've never gone to a dark alley
i've never had okay so brandon give him
[ __ ]
no no he i never said i was trying to
have fun
[Applause]
all right
yeah no i don't yeah you want a dark
alley yeah
if there's lube it's not for the regular
[ __ ] man no
man i've done it once dark alley i've
done it so you said black out
black guys we don't really go to that
but why do people put the cup you know
you know like the third [ __ ] tell me
that hey you know
we don't do that dog hey hey and i'm
just saying that
you know you know what's weird what's
weird in the black culture is like
in the in the locker rooms the guys
would hook up with girls they're like
but did you kiss her
yeah like they thought kissing was a
bigger deal oh yeah their dick sucked
they're having sex or eating no did you
eat a [ __ ] bro like that
remember they're like you were kissing
like she sucked your
dick you better kiss her hero give me
all that
it was big oh you nasty you kissed her
like
i s i tell you guys we're going to train
on that
kiss we're worried about a kiss yeah
yeah bro hell yeah i remember was in the
uh i was telling the story of my homie
cause i mean this girl drank
she's giving me head and all that and
she came up and she tried to kiss me i'm
like come on play that gay [ __ ] i was
like what
yo i swear to god yo did you say that to
here
yeah dark alley yeah see oh but i
expect chickens
i mean i'm pretty sure like if you're in
a couple relationship you kind of try it
at least
you get bored my girls not my girl
chin gets a little dumpling growing
y'all never had crab wontons
the return of the king is here we've all
been waiting for it man the most
notorious man
in the sport we talk about that conor
mcgregor the chosen one be sure to check
out draftking sportsbook
when you're watching the fights the
official sportsman partner of the ufc
and guess what you have a shot to turn
one dollar and 257
that's right new users bet one dollar
mcgregor to win by knockout in the first
round
if he does you'll be cash in 257
buckos bet a little win a lot it's that
simple
we're all excited for the ufc but let's
not forget it's playoffs playoffs yep
it's the playoffs
you got the chiefs the bills you got
green bay
tampa bay put your money where their
mouth is at and you can make some bank
on your favorite team
ufc nfl this weekend draftkings are safe
secure reliable make it easy for your
deposit withdraw your money at your
convenience download the top rated
draftking sportsbook app now
use the promo code fighter when you sign
turn one dollar and 257 dollars
if mcgregor wins by first round knockout
says you can do it in 60 seconds so you
could be
making a lot of bucks place your bet and
watch the fist fly this weekend
that's code fighter for new players get
250
dollars if mcgregor wins by first round
knockout for limited time only
after half king sports books must be 21
and older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania only
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
question mark
call wayne hunter gambler in indiana
when you 109 with it
hey budgee would you do it no i wouldn't
bro again you wouldn't do it but i never
said i wouldn't do it
i said my girl don't want to do that
that's a good point you're a different
you want to do it right now
you brought it up to your six figure
queen
it seems friendlier yeah yeah she's like
hey baby you know this lube's for the
dark alley and then put on a darth vader
helmet
you need to go down yeah hey give it a
shot i already don't record back
on wednesday i'm not going in there bro
come back wednesday let us know
wednesday yeah
yeah you need to come back wednesday you
need to stop bullshitting no just saying
don't worry
all right she's not gonna understand
dark alley again
she's okay then use some [ __ ]
words listen look at the
you remember that conversation i had i
was like bro i don't know where we go
from here and then y'all brought lube
into my life
i brought lube into your life that's
justin okay justin
and i'm like bro we thriving we don't
need anything else we have all the
clamps so you don't need the dark kelly
the handkerchief
the my ball you already got the [ __ ]
pink one i put it on my story
we just got the ball dawg we go to the
second shot the pink one right there
yeah yeah right the pink one no go up
that pink and the black one
look at that one right there yeah it's
that one next one is that a [ __ ] toy
what is that that's
the one next to it which one let me next
to it the one where chan what you meant
past
that right there with that thing up oh
the dark vader hell that what the [ __ ]
oh i don't think that's for her it's a
dick right in front of her hell no
what it's a that's a guy that's a guy
those shoulders look at him
yeah no i think a little tip no that's a
guy that's a guy
that's like hellboy so y'all do the ball
thing bro
what is that ball thing for though i
don't know what that's for they can't
talk
yeah you got a safe word yeah of course
we have a safe way i'll be going y'all
but you won't go down the dark alley you
wanna you won't bring that conversation
up no would you bring up a [ __ ] ball
because we like your mouth we like
goddamn dogs it's fantasies though we
like fantasy
already posted on it yeah i posted on it
uh this morning
just just your feet yeah just my feet
like out of bed uh
no of my pedicure yesterday oh
did it go well uh yes so far so good i'm
looking
people signed up uh as of right now
after this episode yeah she's never
talked about it right so know what you
talk about it
literally this morning get the bag
as of right now i have a hundred and
twenty people godzilla that's pretty
good at ten dollars a piece
oh my god that's reasonable nice look at
you you're in covis
yeah yeah i'm not out here trying to rob
people because that'll work
now you don't you don't want to up the
ante with maybe an ass shot
well no i'm good all
you feel good about it yeah it's just my
foot yeah it's my feet no it's totally i
mean even if you want to do more and i
keep roasting that i'm just saying
maybe you want to do more i think it's
pretty normal
it's pretty normal it is did you tell
your folks oh yeah i
talked to my mom about it for like
months because she knows about the joke
and she told me from the get-go
you should do it you should sell
pictures of her look at that and i think
it was last week i talked to my dad on
the phone i was like hey dad how do you
feel if i sold pictures of my feet he's
like
why would people want to see them i told
them it was an american thing
like it's an american fetish and he's
like oh okay well if you can make money
off of it
asians aren't asians sell it i don't
know if they're consuming it unless
you're japanese i feel like japanese
it's japanese
that's a thing yeah japanese people are
really king derek's face
did your sister start only fans no she's
still in the process of trying to get
into love island actually
okay she's on the second round of
auditions right now
yeah last week we talked about how my
sister wanted to get on love island and
a fan actually has a friend who does
casting for them so they reached out to
her and now she's doing her second
sister i've seen cat's sister okay go
ahead pull up a picture
hey i i got an eye appointment yes uh
you're
gonna get you some friends yeah yeah you
can't see bro
look how big a tv we had to get [ __ ]
huge
oh
that guy's right reckless son is damn
unreal holy [ __ ]
unreal who's this black guy yeah let's
see his big brother what the [ __ ] is
that
look at that oh she works out with nle
choppa that's where she works why is
this shirt off
it's a random guy in the gym that [ __ ]
yeah i know i know he wanted to touch
his
calm down yeah why is this shirt off
yeah exactly most of the time
no everyone that goes to that gym has
their [ __ ] their shirt off
everyone's jacked yes everyone's jacked
he's kind of ruined it for me
which one do you guys want is that her
car whoa
yeah is that her car yeah how old is his
car she is 23. she was so nice on the
phone
so helpful yeah yeah cause i called
instead of my in attendance you know
what you wanted to go to
yep why would you do that all the
pictures but
there you go yeah come on you know what
you want bro
exactly this one yeah yeah so
i take all of these photos oh my god a
little stomach action
stomach hello go to her feet let's go go
to the second picture
you can barely see him zoom in she has
some dogs on here
that's the thing about she has some dogs
on her she talks about her feet she used
to play soccer so they're a little rough
okay all right now okay yours not i have
nice we
i have now
your sister told me to call her call her
cat yeah because
my name is cat teen her name is that's
the baby
what is it i go to that picture where
she's showing something on that all the
way to the right
uh this one right there no no oh you see
that one
which one your sister's completely yeah
your sister's super bodied up all right
we're good we got you we got it there
you go
all i'm saying is fans count i'll pay
for it i'll pay for it i'll pay for yeah
she if she wanted extra money i don't
yeah
what's what is love island
no you did it why you asked that
question don't ask that question
we don't have to think about it
i'm sorry
did you say what's lovely how much time
we got left
oh wow you and your girl need something
to do you got to start on season five
of love island uk only i don't [ __ ] with
american i'm [ __ ] with australian
you gotta go uk only it's fantastic
it'll make you want to get in shape
there's dime pieces watch it with your
girl find out her type
oh dude season six this okay here we go
dude comes up this big black
english dude he's probably six six
your girl your sister would love him six
six two eighty
jack fan favorite
did you vote i can't because i'm so
blind
[Applause]
i cannot get enough of it i'm addicted
to that show
i just started season three uh there's
50 episodes
there's some drama about when the girls
who were was on season three
the sex tape stuff the sex tape stuff i
know she's got a sexy that's important
well no so she hooked up with a dude and
it's called revenge porn so let's say
you had a
you got an old girlfriend or a boyfriend
yeah and they released the sex tape
you're [ __ ] under the law like revenge
porn you're [ __ ] dude
like they can't post it you'd be so
screwed because the way that happened is
[ __ ] up well so uh they met
um and they both were on that on tv show
on the challenge
because yeah she was on season three of
love island he was on big brother uk
oh i don't know they got together when
they did the show the challenge on mtv
they were on and off again
there was one day she came over her name
is georgia she comes later
okay but what ends up happening is uh
i guess they hooked up in his house she
left and she didn't know it at the time
but he had cctv
inside of his home he has the only fans
account that he posted that cctv
footage on so she didn't know that he
posted them [ __ ] or that
she was even recording i'd love to see
it but yeah it was taken down
i think oh it was taken down yeah it was
up for a while
you just asked him did you do that he
got arrested
uh the other day on his birthday because
he was in dubai he flew back
right when he landed he was arrested
yeah and now he's dating a 17 year old
he's 32 i think he's a bad guy right
yeah bad guy bad guy
i deleted after i failed me and my girl
i delete it right after why
because i i don't film it then you know
because it's for me in the moment it's
like look at me i'm not one of those
guys
mm-hmm that's you yeah no no sometimes
that's how you roll i'm like looking
yeah
yeah [ __ ] look at that that's my dick
yeah but you guys don't film yourself
sometimes hell no i feel myself trying
to see that
well you have to put it on you you put
it on here
[Laughter]
dude that'd be doing that now uh he'd be
having like these honey girl these
instagrams do you know about him
uh on twitter and he uh what's his name
uh like mr uh something like
oh uh king king king nasir king is here
i like him
like you didn't know who he was until
derek said he was like okay now
no
some dudes out there on the pawn world
that i [ __ ] with who else do you like i
like uh wesley pipes i like how he talks
i don't like that he's progressing i
don't know any male porn
well the only one i believe [ __ ] be
is
i'll be honest yeah
[Music]
try to get your cousin yeah he tried to
try to get her in the porn on the bus
did it work nah she did that he'll just
talk about rainbow
no no no it wasn't the regular bus he's
on the right
no [ __ ] i saw him at the ralph's uh
on magnolia one time brian pumper and he
had this girl she was walking into the
rouse a rouse walking into it with the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
dog [ __ ] walking her in oh yeah
they're filming
probably i mean i'm sure they were yeah
yeah because he was getting high i saw
that episode he's getting all hyped
yeah you started episodes chappelle your
birthday is when uh
23rd the 23rd yeah what day is that
that's saturday
oh it's saturday so we're gonna throw
the party for him on friday yep on
friday yeah yeah we're gonna throw a
party but
yeah you told us we're gonna figure it
out
it was late at night when he came
through the text we have a group taxi
goes yo
birthdays this week we having a pizza
party on friday
i guess we are now and i go chappelle
let's not do ourselves anymore
let's bring it up not bring it up in the
group chat let's just
get older and just let it happen oh yeah
we were gonna do it anyway
yeah buddy he was like pizza or helen
ray's i guess dude yeah
i put it i put it all caps how the race
that was funny it was like it came late
too it wasn't like a normal hour that
was like he was thinking about it yeah
oh you were like what am i gonna send
this did you think we were gonna forget
honestly no really no yes no
i will say this about you man you are
good about birthdays i'm all right
you know you remember
i mean but we did something for malik i
think we did something for
who else's birthday everyone's birthday
we usually do july 5th
no close two days off
oh july 7th no july july 2nd july 3rd
thursday july 20th
helen race huh you know you should do
the spicy for your b day
i will no i want to up my level because
last time i got the medium you don't
want that i'm gonna do the hot
yeah hot would be good for you yeah it's
it's not just a little bit i've seen
what it is yeah i remember i was i got
freaking
tearing like a balloon red yeah his face
is already tastes so nice
you handle hot [ __ ] oh bro i love it
dude hot [ __ ] that [ __ ] extra hot
bag of hot cheetos you wear this all
week right yeah i'm here all week yeah
yeah say less yeah we'll do the hot
okay you like it that pizza we had it
was that last
is that friday last year
i'm gonna have to say that's my number
one out here because prince is racist
take racism out of it it keeps saying
that
we're just talking about pizza that's a
big checkup
i don't know what you're talking about i
don't know what they put on the dms
out
that cheese was the hitter yeah the
cheese slices yeah really cool
yeah we got good yeah it looks good yeah
we gotta get you a slice they ain't got
pizza in baltimore do they
no they have pizza oh you
there's nothing right here i know i'm
starving i know i am too as well
bro i went to the fan requesting me to
get a haircut and
i was like take a little off the top and
he gave me the chin he he gave it no no
don't do [ __ ] like that
you got the national guard damn why are
you yeah
you should wear a hat you wear hats it's
not bad now it's not good let's be
honest not good
it's not it's not the melody the fade's
not good the fade is not good right
it just goes from a zero to a three or
something there's no like you know
there's no blend yeah this is just like
because because you want to see the
waves though your hair's [ __ ] up
you didn't look [ __ ] up you didn't
look at his ig you didn't look at his
eyes
[ __ ] up no no no no it's the ways you
don't see here's the thing the waves of
fire yeah
so you don't you don't blend when you
have the waves that's not supposed to be
a fade not okay
wait wait it's supposed to be it's
supposed to be but it's like a real
quick fade right yeah quick uh yeah
yeah yeah that's called the peanut
butter falcon the peanut butter falcon
hello put your head up don't don't put
yourself put your hand up you got the
full metal jacket fade
bro no tomorrow this is 360 waves right
here they tagged me and all that they
tagged you no but i want that
name you didn't look at this dude's uh
instagram no i'm not feeling
the back is the back isn't that bad it's
not wait wait wait are you sleeping
i'm not feeling it you got the rain man
you do need to work on the back a little
bit i will say wait the way he's not
hitting him it's just
how you get those waves bro now you've
been with me
for a year oh yeah haven't touched my
hair all i do is like i push it back
no that's what i got i've never i've
never i haven't touched her but
anything in his hair cut this is they
came they cut the waves into it
no he just is naturally what's
underneath his hair his hair is natural
like that they know he ain't no
no perm kid nothing like that no we're
looking at my hair
don't even [ __ ] eyes
like you see did you see where he looked
he was like
this is a lifestyle yeah and that's and
that's fun that's his vibe you had never
you'd never get your hair cut oh derek
oh well i was i remember one time i was
working back door to comedy store and
theo came up to me
didn't say anything he and he just goes
he goes man you know you got that hair
man he goes see this right here
before this mullet i was making three
grand a weekend now i'm making 40 grand
just saying anyway yeah and i was like
okay and i'm here now
thanks theo i don't know what that meant
still it's not a lot of help
no i didn't do anything i did nothing i
should have got it
all right give some current events jen
oh i had a question for david
you think i could pull off uh the og uh
the braves raise up top like the faded
yes thank you yes melanie
lewis malcolm you've i know you for a
long time oh bro kiss my
take it from my i take it
this is the guy right here look at this
no disrespect all right wait i thought
you said something positive no no
no no all right set it up i thought it
was gonna be good
yeah really you really set that up no
disrespect but bro
honestly bro i love your hair get the
fade like me right
here don't go to his guy wait what no no
i'm not going to that guy that's not my
guy that was a fan request of that yeah
no no no i'm not going to that guy but
i'm saying
get the faith you killed with waves and
all that i could teach you how to have
them
yeah braid it up [ __ ] that go kawhi
leonard yeah let's see what happens
mm-hmm it's nuts this [ __ ] i should just
try it oh deante wilder what's the worst
that's the best one
yeah i think you guys all look good with
it oh thank you thanks jim oh you wanna
go
oh yeah yeah you definitely braid up the
top oh yeah or dread it up just straight
up the top yeah probably travis scott
yeah all right
the other day over in beaverton oregon
there was a man
who was in a parking lot of a grocery
store and he
stole a car the mother who owned the car
was inside grabbing milk and meat but
she
left the car unlocked with her child in
the back seat the child was four years
old
how old four so the guy who
was trying to steal the car took it
realized there was a kid in the back
made a u-turn dropped the kid off
started yelling at the mom saying that
she was irresponsible
and that he may call the police on her
right he then drove off with the car
yeah i like this guy yeah yeah i like
this guy i respect that
you leave the car on a four-year-old
unlocked so you can get milk you [ __ ]
idiot and stuff
you know i like the dude i like that he
was like oh hell i was like yeah
he's about to rob himself he turned him
back around like she
[Music]
but he's also a you know but also he
also sounds like a stand-up guy
yeah i got his back on the street he
still knows what's right and wrong
somewhat kind of what a dumbass though i
like that the mom learned her lesson she
goes
obviously we're thankful he brought the
little one back i mean he had the
decency to do that
yeah and now that i'm thinking back on
it you know he had some points
he was right threatening to call the
police she's all
okay but you stole my car and i'm still
taking the steps
i'm still taking it because you're gonna
learn a lesson
they have not located him yet of course
no they don't need to keep that car
dog all right okay
so snapchat has been on the decline
recently with all these new social media
sites and
in the attempt to try to get users back
onto their platform
they're they have a new feature called
spotlight and it's basically like their
version of tick tock
and what they're doing is every single
day they're going to be giving out
a million dollars to people who come
onto the platform and create content
like tick tock
and then they like randomly pick someone
to win the million uh
it's people who get a share of a million
so let's say
mal gets on snapchat he makes a funny
video and he gets a good amount of views
they then pay him
for the work that he did trying to get
users back onto the platform
this has been happening i believe since
november and there are a few teenagers
who have already made millions of
dollars three million really
it says november
we don't know how long they're going to
continue to do this but this is in an
attempt to try to get people back onto
their platform yeah i can't see myself
getting on snapchat
honestly snapchat died when instagram
started having stories
so the fact that because that was the
snapchat that was a snapchat thing and
then take time
to kill instagram for sure well no
instagram can never die you know
hell no what are you talking about tic
toc is better bro it doesn't you're
going to put it better than ig
yeah i bet that i'll bet that too that's
not a thing you got to stop gambling
that's not even a thing
to be gambled i don't know how we're
going to bat
that is true i bet tick tock but you
like snapchat no i'm just saying like so
like i think there's space for both of
them a
young man it's the young man it's the
young it's a young cool thing
yeah also what i like about snapchat is
you can get famous off of it
anybody like a mom in [ __ ] texas like
anybody
remember vine people was getting famous
off that the same exactly so i'm saying
and where's mine right now
but this is better than mr graham kane
robertson that's right and bro all right
you see people got big on five people
yeah i know yeah they're telling me yeah
yeah
yeah yeah but the paul brothers they did
yeah the paul brothers they were viners
oh wow oh that's great how cool is that
well you see vine no i'm saying now look
at vine you you use what you're giving
right now tick tock is hot
but instagram was always look they got
real you know who never goes away
facebook just stays stays
right just kind of owns everything it
owns all really yeah yeah
it owns instagram oh gotta get it
snapchat snapchat i forgot who owns
snapchat i think they sold to a bigger
company a while ago
yeah facebook what about twitter twitter
i don't know i don't know who's twitter
it's too much to keep up with you know
but they're paying
a million dollars to people like i say
people yeah up to yeah i got some ideas
already
jump on but like yeah it seems like it's
still like a younger thing though
um i think everything is more geared
towards a younger generation because
they're the ones on
yeah so you gotta cater to who's yeah
on it yeah mm-hmm uh the people that won
like was
got the million dollars uh yeah they're
younger guys
age ranges but a lot of the people who
are making the money now are younger
just because they're the ones who are on
these platforms
already but jason gorilla
rule is older but he didn't hop on until
later yeah
that's the thing he was also already
jason derulo yeah he was already jason
bro y'all look alike who you and jason
no no you and jason darula
no i don't think they look a lot thanks
no y'all oh i see it wrote the jokes but
why are you saying it like it's a bad
thing to look like jason
he is a fine ass man
you think everyone is ugly unless they
look like you that's no no no no no no
no i'm not
you said michael b jordan was okay no i
know i said he was he's a bit of a hater
who me yeah no i'm not
waiting we tried to compare the vikings
i tried to back up the picture no i said
the sexiest man alive when he won that i
said it was rigged that's all i said
about it and i said you're chrysler 300
and he's a rolls-royce
yeah well look that's a great way to put
it well again he had work done
what work michael jordan had work oh his
teeth
oh teeth yeah teeth you're a hater
i just want to look like me don't i
don't want to look like anyone else i
want to look like but they're good
references i don't think it was yeah
yeah jason dorillo is that a good
reference yeah you look like jason
derulo tell me why i look like
can you go back to that i think it was
just the same as like you know
smile smile like that
[Music]
yeah dude the smile yeah bro go to the
one with his shirts off with his shirt
off yeah take your shirt off man
or this one take your shirt off and i'll
hold you like that bro now if you have a
picture on your instagram like that
what you talking about he's a little
thicker than he's a little thicker who's
a sad asian dude in the back
this dude taking pictures bro that's how
you stand on stage
dude yeah he's super talented look at
that schlong that's a banana right
no he's just i'm really into that that's
his date guys yeah
that's dangerous that's not expensive
you don't think that photo trended
because of that
dick yeah cause he got famous that he
had a piece on him no he didn't get
famous because of that he was already
famous
this is like a lady this photo went
viral like remember the game was posted
too much
holy
yeah it's fantastic after a certain
amount of them though
this is for men like five times
it's not this is for not for women
anymore it's not you're just trying to
brag now you're just this is foreign
like if they see a picture like that
they're like all about it yeah yes i
would much rather have somebody send me
a photo of their dick print like this
than the actual
poster i like the imagination aspect of
it because the dick is ugly
when you see it it's like oh that's a
dick that's a peanut yeah
bro he was taking different angles what
is going on wait that way that's
photoshop right
it's just photoshopped hot photoshopping
is this right this is his ass wait he's
wait he's a photoshop in his pictures
he's photoshopping
i could believe that hold on man hold on
now
maybe bro bro if you photoshopped his
ass you know he photoshopped in the
front
that's a big i wonder if he's hard is it
like he's hard do you think he's soft on
this
i think he's a little chopped up yeah
he's jumped up
he's right he's wrapped up yeah he's
revved he's come on dude he's revved
ready to go
that's a big dick man like we're like
there's no no that is a big
gangster
or not i do got a dick on them
no i'm saying like cat the way dudes
look at like instagram models on ig do
girls do that
for dudes yeah i would say something
yeah yeah
and that would be the photo that would
be the photo yeah that type of [ __ ]
this just all rappers dick prince i
don't know there's a bunch though that's
that doesn't mean
it's waka flocka and that's whiz good
for these guys
damn all right it's a new thing
all right this is just a hollywood
waitress talking about some of the
celebrity guests that came into our
restaurant
and it went viral for some reason but
i'll just play it for you
my husband and i were born and raised in
los angeles and we've also been in the
service industry i got some teeth
on it and we had to say it celebrities
seven years ago my husband served
christina aguilera
and she was not nice asked what she
wanted to drink she just stared at him
gave him the evil eye
looked at her manager and her manager
basically had to talk to
my husband because she refuses to talk
to the staff what
if your husband sucks miley cyrus and
liam hemsworth with
obviously they were still together both
super nice like
i can't stop saying that a team and
miley was like
low-key hitting on my husband but that
never happened no yeah
that never happened bill nye and that
guy sucks
[ __ ] you bill nye the science guy yeah
yeah [ __ ] she's probably trying to
solve [ __ ]
you got time trying to figure out the
weather you
[ __ ] door so anymore
oh she was just trying to get content oh
yeah
yeah like there was a big thing about
haley bieber being rude and she came out
and apologized for it
yeah because a lot of people do these uh
i think it went viral because there was
a girl
who's based out of new york so that she
worked at a really fancy restaurant in
new york
and she started rating people based off
of like yes celebrities she said the
hadids were really nice
and then she talked about haley bieber
and so that bieber was really rude to
her
haley bieber saw that ended up
apologizing and saying like oh thanks
for doing this to keep me accountable
but oh weird it's weird bro that only
means one thing when somebody says
they're like you serve them and you were
rude
you didn't tip well that's all that
means yeah that that means i didn't like
the tip you gave them
something like oh they were so nice they
left a fact because you're thinking
about do they really care like when
you're just sitting there and you're not
that talkative no they don't give a [ __ ]
no they don't know you're gonna sit down
and like
have a [ __ ] full-blown podcast with
the waitress yeah mm-hmm
that's right no that's that's yeah it
has to be a tip thing they didn't you
didn't because
bro you worked at the comedy show that's
how i was like oh what comedians was
cool the [ __ ] the one that tipped in a
lot yeah yeah that's what's cool
who's not cool they say don't tip what
do you mean it's a simple game
like no that's [ __ ] don't talk about
bill nye [ __ ] that [ __ ]
i didn't know he's still alive but yeah
yeah yeah you think everyone's dead
i haven't heard from him
this is uh lebron james he has that new
hummer ev oh yeah i saw this yeah but
the video kind of sucks right because
it's like this way and now like that let
me see
it was more it's more for him though
yeah
because these aren't out yet right nah i
don't think so
wait let's see if this video is over
here the electric uh hummer yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah do you think they do you
think they give them those
yeah here we go
porsche didn't give him that 918 spider
oh yeah
i hope everybody doing well got a little
sneak peek i want to show y'all
all right y'all ready for it
it's probably sexy right waiting on it
you couldn't see it at first like what
if we're waiting on it that's kind of
[Music]
yep the rims are dope yeah that's clean
put some 4g she's like such a wholesome
guy
look at the top too oh yeah i changed
your mind a little bit top
that's actually [ __ ] fine yeah i
think yeah
listen to my man
huh you know that cash [ __ ] that's that
cash check
yeah i bet gmc paid a good amount that
is pretty pretty good
yeah yeah that's fire yeah y'all check
out this
time he was on both sides
damn thank god that is dope wow yeah i
[ __ ] with this
zero to 60 in three seconds insane
really look at those people back there
no idea crab walk
meaning i can go sideways in this thing
that's awesome
that's hard yeah what does that mean
crab walk you can go like this yeah
drip into a parking lot crabs
when did you become fahim
yeah he has a dope car collection yeah
that's dude he has a billion dollars so
yeah your car is gonna be cool you know
yeah
that's the top off though that was nice
what was that what was that when he said
he had that
before he didn't get 918 spider that's
how much that's the million dollars
two million dollar car yeah you know how
many
are in the world it's not a ton yeah
yeah
another one shout out to lebron yeah oh
he revealed a lot that the car and space
jam 2 this weekend yo space champion
looks fine
it's dope right the rock has another tv
show coming out it's about his life oh
cool i need more rock
and roll what's up adam ray's on this
show oh
nice i'm not sure if i can play this on
the show but i'll just play you guys
the trailer
uh yeah i mean i don't watch those those
shows on like abcmc you don't really
watch
they're so lame well hold on it's the
chicago pd is good it's so
corny it's some great nine-nine is
though it's some corny
[ __ ] nine-nine it's funny like they're
like i'll have a vodka tonic
i'm out like off that i'm out you know
i might check out an episode what about
you i'm watching it you're watching i
like i like to rock man yeah i like the
rock yeah
i love the rock as well adam ray playing
his voice like he would call adam ray
and they were like they're cool like
that i mean his voicemails were so funny
bro cuz it's just
it's normal [ __ ] but it's just a rock
going like hey buddy
guess we miss each other guess we're
playing phone tag anyway
love you
update on dr dre he's actually back in
the studio he almost died
yeah with the aneurysm yeah but there he
is at the studio look at him looking
great
he does look good i know it looks like
randy moss is behind him
and the do-rag yes guy yeah
dude he's my favorite commentator moss
that [ __ ] accent i love that that
country oh my god i mean patrick mahomes
man he's got he's got a head on his
shoulders man
how do you talk like that dude because
if you're thinking like bro you're a six
four dominator dominant and he gets
watch one at the ball
and the quarterback threw me the ball
i'm like i mean i went up there and i
snacked that stuff
i snatched that mid-air man fish
you got to go but he doesn't really
break it down he's like you gotta go up
there and get it
not everyone is blessed like even well
he sounds like an offensive line coach
like all the people he does
bro uh i'mma repost something for
thanksgiving what are you bros brother
he's like y'all mm-hmm yeah i know what
y'all i'm out here doing
caught me a little bass this morning
i didn't know he's like country bro
marshall yeah him and deon sanders
they're like [ __ ]
actually country boys yeah oh really but
then i can hide it though yeah
prime time commercials you saw his son
uh going to jackson state i love that i
love it he's coach and you see beyond
his coach on the jackson street
head coach i love that [ __ ] damn
remember last week giannis papas was
talking about floyd mayweather yeah and
his wife
he sent me our this morning goes how
obvious can it get
go hit i know what you're gonna do yeah
so floyd just posted about these
i guess it's like the anniversary or
something like that when she passed away
uh but then he has these posts by his
wife there's like two of them
yeah there's this one too he cut he
turned comments off turns comments off
yeah that makes sense
the other pictures other stuff he
doesn't turn comments off but those he
does
i guess that's your wife yeah yeah but
then the the theory was
that he potentially allegedly
is the one that made her go away
yeah it gets pretty dicey conspiracy uh
drug overdose fentanyl at nine in the
morning in front of the driver
with him and she was gonna write a
tell-all book but she doubted that no
whether she has no history or no no no
evidence of drugs on her
or something like that it's super
suspense yeah that's really [ __ ]
creepy man i didn't know that i didn't
think about it till [ __ ]
you honest brought it up you probably
did it what are you
gonna do what will you do what are we
gonna do what are we gonna do some boys
should have i don't know what their
relationship was people go missing all
the time
i don't know i don't know what happened
who doesn't do fentanyl at 9 00 am on
the starbucks run
how do you guys get going i bet he wrote
i
i imagine because you can't spell or
read i i bet he wrote a real shitty
suicide love
and his boys are like nah nah nah you
miss about everything
you miss about her name that's not how
you spell her name
can't we can't use this we can't use it
like
[Music]
he's like dude she wouldn't put that man
wait
where's this fight february oh gets
logan
yeah crazy crazy damn crazy crazy is
that itching calls turnt up
um you want another one good give us one
more all right
this uh artist cj henry where we just
like that yeah i think
oh those are the mags yeah she bought
them for nine thousand dollars and then
she just didn't
dipped him in black paint that's
frustrating but then she sold that and
she made enough money to buy
a hundred thirty thousand dollars uh
worth of shoes for people
for kids in new york so let me see it so
she dips them and then we should argue
that just becomes the art right there oh
that's sick
that's a perfect one that's the shoe
from back to the future yes
and then she'll just sell the photos i
would buy that painting
would you buy the shoes though yeah dude
i would
he wants them to do something strange
for those shoes
what those are like the ultimate shoe
yeah but yeah do something
strange what you mean what are we
talking about man
what's up are we back on the loop right
here
man this crew next week [ __ ] it's next
week already next
friday saturday uh san marcos texas
at the mark uh in san marcos texas right
outside austin right side san antonio
two shows friday two show saturday
that's january 29th 30th
the only tickets left were the ten uh
cedar tables
they got smart they broke them up so now
those are down to four
uh tables so go get em and that's all
the tickets left i don't mean comps
nothing don't hit me up
um
how can i get in the show yeah
that sounded like it was for a specific
concert
people always hit me up but then yeah so
get your tickets because they just made
more available
tfatk.com or f-a-t-k-z-dot-com
for all the tickets for san marcos texas
next week friday the collab with
specialized drop at thick boy
thickboy.com
i'll be posting all of my stories all up
in the video thick boy specialized
collab
drops this [ __ ] friday thickboy.com
get them
derek poston we'll see you wednesday
yeah i'll be back here
welcome to the crib yeah we're out
uh the one and only you can't call me
got a lot of haters and a lot of homies
some friends and some phony um today i'm
rocking
[Laughter]
someone watch sesame
[Laughter]
you know tranny's dropping panties out
there you know what i'm saying
hey i see you in the game you know uh
yeah bro we're doing the fit
yeah brendan bought me these i'm a broke
[ __ ]
i got you i gave you those for your
b-day for my birthday that's what i say
you're good with birthdays
that's love your birthday's in march
yeah october oh oh yeah october 25th
close look at you you're working
tomorrow no october 25th
did you hear me say it right though
malik
he's the off-white version of the hair
boys one stop bro
this is from the car the weight i'm
blowing two grand a month on lube dog
like that yeah there we go okay you blow
up two grand a month on loop and i'm
gonna do butt stuff
bro hold on bro yeah
don't forget the ball bro don't forget
the ball in the middle we do balls
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] all these hoes check
out the dog walker son you ain't gonna
see
this yeah you just kept the whole shoe
camp okay check this out looks like you
stepped in doo doo doo
polish it's doo doo baby ooh that's just
dude
hey when you go inside we need to do
this
that you get some [ __ ]